[Musique]
l'impôt sur la fortune isf
emmanuel macron l'avait promis il l'a
supprimée le 1er janvier 2018 selon lui
l' isf n'était rien d'autre qu'un
matraquage fiscal néfastes pour
l'économie du pays
est-ce que ça a rapporté beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent
lisez les chiffres avec magnifique non
pourquoi parce que les gens qui
réussissent et ils sont partis une
suppression dénoncé à gauche et par les
gilet jaune qui descendait dans la rue
onze mois plus tard la première des
choses c'est de remettre liées cette
fois c'est très important
c'est psychologiquement il faut que tout
le monde participe et aujourd'hui en
pleine crise sanitaire des voix
s'élèvent pour le retour de cet impôt
afin de financer la presse dsf à 10 et
16 10 ses débuts qu'il a déchaîné les
passions 1981 françois mitterrand en
fait sa promesse de campagne
je confirme ici que conformément aux
engagements présidentiels
nous présenterons à l'automne un projet
dapo déclaratif sur les grandes fortunes
l'impôt est fortement critiquée à droite
et à peine instauré en 1986 le
gouvernement de jacques chirac le
supprime
d'abord c'est un impôt qui rapporte très
peu aidé coûte très cher à mettre en
oeuvre
deux ans plus tard la gauche et de
nouveaux pouvoirs et l'impôt sur les
grandes fortunes et réinstaurer sous la
forme de liesse f1 impôts censés
financer le rmi l'impôt sur la fortune
est une contribution de solidarité
pas une revanche contre les riches à
partir de cette date cet impôt sera sans
cesse réformer le seuil
d'assujettissement par exemple passera à
la fin du mandat de nicolas sarkozy de
800000 euros à 1,3 million d'euros ce
qui n'empêche pas le nombre d'assujettis
d'augmenter à nouveau après 2012 mais
aussi aux recettes de grimper jamais
l'impôt sur la fortune n'avait rapporté
autant d'argent il y a deux ans c'était
4,4 milliards d'euros 5,2 milliards
d'euros l'an dernier et l'état prévoit
même 5,6 milliards d'euros en 2015
malgré ses recettes pour le gouvernement
actuel cet impôt était temps
tractage fiscal faisant fuir les
capitaux hors de france
le but de sa suppression était alors de
réinjecter de l'argent en france au
service de l'économie
le fameux ruissellement en octobre 2019
le comité d'évaluation de la réforme
devait dire si oui ou non la suppression
de l' isf avait doper l'investissement
réponses des experts
il est encore trop tôt pour le dire
[Musique]